allez on a le dos et des faits qui vous
sont reprochés alors les plaignants la
spa et les charcutiers de france
je veux faire goûter monsieur
c'est un nouveau produit que nous
sortons en france si ceux ci sont des
chiens 100% pur bête
donne envie de gerber pourquoi ces deux
chiens oui
avec du chien
c'est du bâton de berger allemand
on a du jambon du yorkshire on a on a de
la rose est fait avec des teckels savez
les teckels c'est toulon ça la formule 1
106 ont déjà on les met directement dans
la machine cacak on les ficelles
c'est pas des bâtards quand même un csi
a porté les miens bien vigoureux et sur
le poil brillant
c'est sublime c'est un nouveau produit
qui vient de sortir c'est fait avec des
chiens
au revoir c'est malheureux pour les
verts bon c'est malheureux c'est vrai
c'est pas des chiens domestiques non
plus un cd chien de laboratoire ouais
ils sont eux rien on les en palmant le
viaduc oui pourquoi pas ou des escargots
et sa cdu c'est du passé
ben si vous en avez mangé vous allez
manger du teckel gm ans j'y suis là
j'ai envie de faire une blague à des cop
alors leur faire bouffer avec une
bouteille de rouge à leur faire bouffer
du saucisson de chien qu'il est bon je
sais que là bas ils ont des boucheries
de chiens ronald même si c'est vrai et
c'est des bestiaux qui sont élevés ah
ouais c'est pas des domestiques c'est
l'annoncé d'un chien de laboratoire oui
bien sûr les chiens qui sont élevées
parce qu'ils sont recueillis à la spa et
puis quand la sp un peu plus les garder
et ils vont directement charcuterie
merci mais si c'est vrai mais ça a
toujours existé j'ai déjà dit que j'ai
mangé du chien en allemagne voilà et les
bons ou pas bons mais bon c'est un bon
toutou à sa mémère ça passe à maurepas
sa mort plus surtout
avec avril à mieux vaut avoir des
trottoirs propres et bien manger que des
trottoirs sales et manger de la merde
c'est sûr mais ça c'est sûr
[Musique]